my founding story and you can shape your
business life or your working life you
can just look at it as another extension
you just fulfill all your values of the
human being in the workplace if you're
an activist you bring the activism of
your life into your business or if you
love creative art you can bring that it
Anita Roddick down through the body shop
and pioneer of ethical consumerism I
never wanted to tell my story when i
started my website i wanted to build a
great resource to help entrepreneurs
succeed i started with stories of famous
entrepreneurs like Bill Gates Oprah
Winfrey and Walt Disney because their
stories inspired me when I was down when
I doubted myself when I felt like I
wasn't going to make it I look to their
stories and they motivated me to keep
going bill gates of story saved my
business and made me stick with being an
entrepreneur I wanted to share that
knowledge with others so they could also
be motivated to continue to pursue their
dreams I created an awesome website that
people kept writing in saying love the
site but who is Evan Carmichael I'm
nobody compared to the entrepreneurs I'm
profiling I thought but people were
asking so i started to share and my
business took off suddenly it was
attracting more clients more website
traffic more social media followers i
was selling more products getting more
newsletter signups receiving more media
requests for interviews I was having
more fun to the product i had was
already great but when i told my story
it added more context it made it feel
more valuable it connected with people
when i talked about how i was making
three hundred dollars a month to my
first business and Bill Gates a story
save my company and help me build an
international business and get acquired
just a couple of years later that adds
context people really want to hear what
I have to say I realized that telling my
story wasn't about pumping myself up a
humanized my business I made it easier
for people to take whatever next step I
was asking them to taste
it's time for you to write your story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]